you may remember that a few months ago
some members of faze clan were wrapped
up in what appeared to be a massive
crypto scandal some members were
suspended from phase but one member k
was removed from the organization
altogether we thought it might end there
but now kaye has come forward and blamed
the entire thing on one of the most
controversial people in youtube's
history the weird just got a whole lot
weirder
[Music]
okay so with this story we've talked
about it before we're talking about it
now and there's a chance we may talk
about it in the future so make sure
you're subscribed to score esports and
that way you'll never miss any of this
news or any of the other great videos we
make on this channel do it okay so in
his 27 minute long explanation video k
has come forward with a bunch of new
information that makes this strange
crypto situation even stranger but
before i get into that let's just
explain how we even got here so back in
june we covered the initial scandal at
the time phase was taking a lot of heat
because it appeared that some of their
members jarvis tico nikken and kaye may
have been promoting a crypto coin that
had all the hallmarks of a pump and dump
scheme whenever we talk about this it's
important to have a basic understanding
of how crypto works and devon did a
great job of summarizing all of that in
our previous video think of it as a
peer-to-peer interaction i send you
bitcoin it's acknowledged and validated
that i have the funds to do so by the
blockchain system and then you get the
money very very simply put think of the
blockchain system as the infrastructure
used to house all of the transactions
carried out by cryptocurrencies
everyone and anyone can look at these
transactions at any time if they want to
it's basically like a digital ledger
book and if you're already familiar with
crypto it's probably because of the
massive explosion of crypto coins over
the last few years cryptos such as
bitcoin and ethereum pave the way and
now many people are following in their
success by creating their own crypto
seriously everyone and their mom seems
to be making a coin at the minute of
course this opens up the possibility for
abuse like say if you've got a lot of
fans on youtube you can start up your
own cryptocurrency which you own a lot
of convince your fans to then buy into
that crypto and then sell all of your
crypto when it's at its peak value for a
lot of money pump it and then dump it if
you will once the owners of the crypto
sell their overvalued shares the price
plummets and anyone who's left holding
on to the currency finds that it's now
essentially worthless pump and dump
schemes like this have been around for
centuries but despite this people are
now doing it with crypto and it still
works this is what the phase clan
members were accused of being involved
with that they and others helped promote
a cryptocurrency also known as an
altcoin called save the kids they had a
professional looking site that promised
that for every transaction of a save the
kids token one percent of the three
percent tax would be donated to charity
they assured any potential investors
that they had a public charity wallet
that would automate transactions
straight to the wallet of a group called
binance now binance is a cryptocurrency
exchange and the save the kids
transaction amount was supposed to go to
their lunch for children campaign which
aims to feed children in remote regions
of africa the site was supposed to
assure potential investors that this was
all above board charity-minded and
definitely not a pump and dump scheme a
video on the site which no longer exists
featured long-standing faze clan members
such as jarvis tico nikken and k as well
as controversial youtuber ricegum acting
as ambassadors for the launch
my name's frasier my name is jarvis i'm
tico i'm ricegum i'm nikon and i support
save the kids tokens save the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token
in the lead-up to the launch the coin
was being heavily promoted by the
ambassadors on social media who seemed
eager for their followers to also get
their hands on save the kids tokens
saying a project like this had never
been done before and that the charity
aspect would change people's lives when
the coin launched on june 5th it rose
quickly in value as people bought in but
as you can see from this graph it then
sharply dropped off everyone who had
invested in those first few days now
found that their save the kids tokens
were worth practically nothing the whole
thing had boomed and busted in a matter
of days this caused a lot of suspicion
about the whole thing just being a pump
and dump scheme as the currency
continued to fall in value youtubers
such as some ordinary gamers raise their
concerns you can see that at some point
some way back if you go all the way to
06 all right if you go just all the way
back here you can see save the kids so
they ended up receiving from the
deployer address from what i assume part
of a pre-sale if you will they've got
16.6 million tokens and immediately
literally 0605 0605 an hour later they
started flooding that market to pancake
swap and selling and selling and selling
at buying finance pegs so bsc usd they
were selling and selling and selling and
selling and that's not the only account
i have spent like 30 minutes just
vetting this myself and have come to the
conclusion that this is something that
is wholly unreliable it is using save
the kids in order to create this weird
token that is so obviously pump and dump
that anybody all right even with the
worst eyesight could have seen this
coming another youtuber who put a lot of
work into this was coffeezilla now he
claimed to find evidence that phase k
had sold all of his save the kids tokens
within 24 hours of the currency's launch
not only that he said that k has a
history of doing this with crypto what
i'm trying to say is this is a pattern
of deceiving his fans pumping something
and selling it to his fans so he gets
the best price how much money did he
make from it we'll try to calculate that
later and by the way if it feels like
i'm belaboring this point i am phase k
has consistently deceived his audience
by pushing crypto to them while having a
bag of crypto given to him by these
coins i guess for promotions and selling
it immediately to them coffeezilla and
some ordinary gamers did an immense
amount of investigating into all of this
between them their videos covered this
topic as comprehensively as you can
possibly get so it's important to
remember here that the implication of
this being a pump and dump scheme was
and is alleged these things can be
pretty difficult to prove save the kids
have publicly stated that their
ambassadors were not given tokens to be
the faces of the project and that they
did it solely because they believed in
the mission but still even though
nothing had been proven the negative
attention of faze clan received had
reached a boiling point by the end of
the month on july 1st faze put out a
statement saying that they had removed
kaye and suspended jarvis nikken and
tico from the organization adding that
they had no involvement with their
members activity in cryptocurrency and
strongly condemned their behavior for
those of you who don't know kay and
jarvis are brothers we covered jarvis at
the end of 2019 when he was permanently
banned from fortnite for aimbot cheating
according to jarvis himself this means
that he was banned for life from playing
fortnite he dropped this news in a very
emotional video over the weekend i'm
truly like so sorry epic i know i have
to take accountability for my actions
and you know i'm gonna i'm gonna do my
best to accept any punishment like comes
my way before his removal from faze was
announced k had tweeted out that he felt
like he'd let his fans down and that it
was irresponsible of him to promote the
coin without knowing more so fazer said
they had nothing to do with it the
ambassadors were reportedly just the
face of it and nobody had come forward
and admitted that this was a pump and
dump then on july 9 kay released a short
video in which he addressed the
accusations he was facing all i'm
allowed to say right now is this please
please do not believe what you're
hearing online all of these people
making videos think that they know the
truth and that they know who's
responsible when they just don't so this
is the truth all right i lost money on
save the kids token but what actually
upsets me the most is that anybody else
was hurt
so we've uncovered significant evidence
which confirms that a dishonest person
abused his trust with me to scam
everybody over a month pass with no word
from k about who he thought the mystery
perpetrator was behind the save the kids
mess but on august 13th he published a
video called what really happened with
save the kids and named the individual
as none other than sam pepper trusting
him obviously now i realized was a
massive mistake he took charge without
anyone's permission and started to make
all of the decisions his control and
power influenced the main dev who
literally felt obliged to do what sam
said sam helped design the token the art
for the token the website for the token
and phil the pre-sale and he made all of
the decisions that led to this current
situation now if you don't know who sam
pepper is he's probably one of the most
controversial figures in youtube's
history in 2014 he posted a prank video
in which he used fake arms to pinch the
backsides of unsuspecting women on the
street the controversy around that
resulted in a number of women coming
forward and saying that he'd sexually
assaulted them as well as one account of
alleged rape he also received immense
backlash for a 2015 prank video where a
person was convinced that their best
friend had been shot and killed by
hostage takers right in front of their
eyes in the wake of all this sam pepper
announced that he was quitting the
internet forever and while this may have
been true for a while he has since made
a return he began live streaming on
youtube in 2018 alongside the likes of
ice poseidon and then in 2019 he took up
tick tock as his main content platform
where he now has over 4 million
followers posting challenge and vlog
videos so if you haven't heard of this
guy since 2016 you may be surprised to
find out that he's the one that k is
pinning all of this on in his video k
said that he hired sam to essentially
run his youtube channel for him but when
sam got more into crypto he felt that
sam wasn't dedicating enough focus to
his videos and the relationship became
strained according to him he was more
focused on crypto projects like save the
kids and so he eventually let him go as
his producer in the video k then goes
into save the kids anti-whaling policy
an anti-whaling policy is essentially a
feature that's hard-coded into a
cryptocurrency to stop people who own a
large amount of it from selling in one
go it's supposed to be a protection
against the pump and dump schemes that
we talked about earlier the thing is
people have their suspicions that that's
exactly what happened and well kate had
an answer for that sam insisted the devs
to make the change to the well code his
reasoning at the time was that the
people in the pre-sale wouldn't be able
to sell enough of their tokens it was
completely sam's idea to make this
change and it would only be revealed
later on in our investigation as to why
he did that and while kay said he had no
knowledge of any of this and that it was
all sam's idea coffeezilla spoke to one
of the contracted developers called
lucas whose story seems to contradict
that just for reference here frasier is
kaye's real name and manny is the name
of one of the mysterious orchestrators
of the project that lucas received
instructions from at first because of
the big names that were supposedly
involved in this project lucas was
suspicious of the offer to work on save
the kids this was me being proven that
this was actually influencers weren't
bored on this and i was like oh okay
obviously i would work for somebody like
that like i want to work for a project
where there's like people behind that's
crazy it's gonna be huge if i had i
guess my argument would be if i had
direct connections
then i wouldn't have to be sent a
picture like this that was like to prove
to me
so i guess that is what i'm trying to
show it says lucas and man
lucas and manny on this to your mind
does this mean that frasier was in on
this from the get-go like even on the
premeditation of this app because it
doesn't seem like he was brought in as
an afterthought
it seems like he was in this from the
beginning i assume all the influencers
probably were in this from the beginning
because those were already lined up like
straight off the bat needless to say
here k story doesn't align with that he
said he had no idea about any of this
and pins the blame solely on sam pepper
kay claims that he found two of sam's
crypto wallets which show that he made
around 70 000 in a 24-hour period though
he didn't specify that this was in the
24-hour period after the launch and that
the money came from selling save the
kids tokens he also included clips of
him allegedly confronting sam about all
of this over the phone but right now all
the proof i have is that you made a
ton of money sam no idea bro
then help help me help you then all
right help me help you but right now it
looks like you made a ton of money bro
and you've lied to me and said you
didn't and that's what's hurting me the
most kate then goes on to allege that
sam was behind a list of fake accounts
on the save the kids white list the
white list contains people that were
supposed to be brought into the tokens
pre-sale k says that many of them were
fake and that many of their crypto
wallets are actually linked to sam
pepper kay claims that he learned of
these links from crypto detectives he
hired to look into all of this and that
the link was made from seeing multiple
transactions between the fake whitelist
wallets and what k says is a secondary
wallet owned by sam pepper after adding
up the total profits from the sale k
said that it looks like sam made over
330 000 from the whole thing kay also
said that sam abandoned the save the
kids project after launch and supports
this argument with conversations in his
video with the managing director of save
the kids after adding up all the total
profits from the sales k says that it
looks like sam made over 330 000 from
the whole thing kay said that sal
abandoned the save the kids project
after launch and he backs this up in his
video with a conversation with the
managing director of save the kids he
finishes off by providing an email
address and encouraging anyone who lost
money from save the kids to contact him
so he can help fix this kay has since
deleted his twitter if you go to sam
pepper's account he hasn't addressed any
of this he's been tweeting about nfts
for the past few weeks in an interview
with the esports observer attorneys
corey kercher and adrian morse explained
that this whole thing could be a case of
charity fraud which could come with a 1
million dollar fine and up to 30 years
in prison any legal proceedings will
likely expose the true perpetrators of
the save the kids disaster and we'll
have more for you if that happens
if i had a cryptocurrency myself
i think bit burks or burke bits that's
what i call it but the thing is if like
if anything bad happened with it you
know if it just plummeted if it was a
disaster if nobody bought it
my name would always be attached to it
you know
it's a double-edged sword